[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEREMY WALKER: Hello.
Welcome to YouTube Live.
We have a pretty interesting
talk today around Docs, so let
me introduce our guests.
We, of course, have Jeff
Posnick, who's over in the New
York office, and with him we
have Andy Diamondstein, who's
actually our tech writer
for YouTube.
ANDY DIAMONDSTEIN:
How's it going?
JEFFREY POSNICK: Hey, Jeremy.
Apologies that we are
sequestered in our little
closet instead of our normal
lush studio in New York City.
We're happy to have Andy
visiting New York and showing
him a good time.
ANDY DIAMONDSTEIN:
Yes, so far.
I'm happy to be here.
JEREMY WALKER: Nice.
Rumor's out there was some
concert or something that
kicked you guys out or something
along those lines.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah.
We were bumped for Blondie,
the band Blondie.
That's the first time and
probably the last time I will
ever be able to say that.
So we're broadcasting from a
special undisclosed location
for one week only.
JEREMY WALKER: Nice.
Well, let's jump in, because
this is pretty exciting.
We're going to start asking Andy
some questions and he's
going to fill us in
a little bit.
Tell us a little bit about
what are the improvements
coming with the V3
documentation?
Just give us a little overview
and what we can expect.
ANDY DIAMONDSTEIN: Sure.
When I think about documenting
YouTube services, I really
want us to be able to do three
things with our documentation.
And I think right now, we're
doing maybe one of them in
some places or we're doing two
of them in some places, but
we're not really doing all
three across the board.
Those three things are,
we want to tell you
how something works.
That's what documentation
is for.
It's going to explain
things to you.
We do a really good job of that,
I think, or I hope, with
the current documentation
for the Version 2 API.
Then the next step is we want
to, in addition to telling you
how it works, to show
you how it works.
That would involve integrating a
lot of code samples into the
documentation so that when you
read about, OK, well you've
told me how to upload a video.
Show me how to upload a video.
Give me some code, and give me
code in different languages
and code samples that I can
actually use in my own code.
Showing you how it works would
involve code samples and
non-interactive demos.
The third thing is we want to
actually let you play with the
functionality yourself, and test
it out, and see how it
works by using it.
That would involve interactive
demos.
In the new API, we have
something called the API
Explorer, which lets you fill
out parameter values for
different requests, and you
can see the request that's
being submitted and the response
that would come back.
An example of somewhere where
we do that right now is with
the YouTube Player demo, which
I think we'll talk about a
little bit later.
That's something where you can
test out a player, and see how
it works, and configure it
yourself, and then take the
code and apply it in your
own application.
Being able to do all three
of those things is really
important for a complete
set of documentation.
To get there, we're going
to build on some of the
advantages of the platform that
the API is using, that
it's a standard platform for the
current Google APIs that I
think you guys have
talked about in--
JEFFREY POSNICK:
Yeah, we have.
Specifically, Andy's talking
about what's going to apply to
the Docs for Version 3 of the
data API and for the new
YouTube Analytics they've got,
both of which were built on
this standard platform.
We could make use of the API
Explorer and a bunch of other
standard resources.
Another nice thing about having
a standard platform--
if you are using multiple
Google APIs in the same
projects, things should
look familiar to you.
If you've read through the
Google+ Docs, the new YouTube
API docs should also have
a very similar format.
That helps, too.
ANDY DIAMONDSTEIN: Good point.
With the new APIs, we're going
to be able to update client
libraries really frequently,
which I know has been a
challenge with the old APIs.
If it's a bank holiday in France
and the person who
updated, the person who wrote
that client library is there.
We'll be able to update client
libraries really quickly.
And then because they're nice
and nicely integrated with the
API, we can produce code
samples really quickly,
integrate those directly
into the Docs.
Documentation for the new API
is also generated in large
part from the code base.
One of the challenges with
an API that has a lot of
functionality and a lot of
developers working on it is
just the flow of information
and when developers make a
change, knowing that that's
happening and communicating it
to you guys, the developers,
as soon as it's available.
Being able to generate
documentation from the code
base will make that a much
simpler process so that as
changes go into the code base,
we'll be able to update the
documentation almost
automatically and get that
functionality documented
for you really quickly.
JEFFREY POSNICK: That, in
particular, will be great.
Right now, the flow sometimes
looks like some external
developer happens to notice that
one of the responses in
the API isn't quite the same
as it used to be, and then
they will open a bug or they'll
post about it somewhere.
Then I'll find out about it and
I'll tell Andy about it
and Andy will make the changes
and we'll publish it.
Being able to make sure that
the documentation is almost
always authoritative--
obviously, there's still some
manual intervention to say,
get published, more or less.
We don't want docs just flying
out every night willy-nilly.
We do not want to obsolete
Andy among other things.
But it's going to
a nice automated
process to a lot of extent.
ANDY DIAMONDSTEIN: This
isn't a farewell tour.
You might be saying
goodbye to me.
JEREMY WALKER: One thing you
did call out was the API
Explorer which I know when I've
given some talks has been
pretty exciting.
For folks out there that are
new to the V3 APIs, it's
really nice if you want to get
an idea of how it works.
We're RESTful with our V3 API,
but the neat thing is you can
go to this API Explorer.
You can fill out the fields and
it'll generate the URL for
you and then show you what
the response is.
So you can start to see what
different flags do and what
they bring in.
And so you can cut down your
information and things like
that before you even
jump into the code.
I know when I was learning it,
at least V3, that really
helped me, because then I
had a great idea before
I even jumped in.
For instance, I worked a little
bit on the Java samples.
Before I even jumped in, I knew
what to look for, and it
helped me identify and work
through things a lot quicker
than just going at it blind.
So definitely check those out.
Those were pretty popular
in some of our sessions.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Sure.
Would you mind if we take
a few minutes and
demonstrate that live?
JEREMY WALKER: That would
be great, actually.
Let's take a look.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Cool.
I'm going to pull that
up now on our screen.
There are a couple different
ways that you could get to the
API Explorer.
What you'll be able to do moving
forward is go to a
specific section of the Docs.
Right now, I don't know if the
URL is very clearly visible,
but this is developers.googl
e.com/youtube/v3 for Version 3
of the data API.
For instance, right over
here, drilling down--
maybe even a little
bit bigger.
Drilling down to a specific
method in
the Docs search list.
This is how you do
a video search.
So Andy pushed out some right
before we started this show.
I'm not positive of that.
And I'm also not positive this
has anything to do with Andy.
Ideally, down here at
the bottom, there
in this Try It section.
They would be in an embedded
version of the API Explorer
where whenever you're looking at
the method for a particular
call, there's an API Explorer
specifically for that method
on the same page as the docs.
That'll be great.
We'll just figure out why the
current version of the docs
that was just pushed out
doesn't have that.
But there's also a standalone
version of the API Explorer
which is exactly the
same functionality.
It's actually nice having the
on-page version, because you
can see a description of all the
different parameters and
then quickly go down to the
bottom of the page and say,
OK, this is the possible values
for order and then plug
it right in on the same page.
That being said, we'll just go
to the standalone version
which is part of the overall
Google APIs Explorer.
There's a bunch of different
APIs that you
can try this with.
We're on the version for
the data API right now.
I'll also just quickly
mention--
we might talk a little bit
more about this later--
Version 3 of the data
API is still not
fully publicly available.
It's still protected by a
whitelist, and there's a
sign-up process.
Despite that, people can use
this API Explorer even if you
haven't been whitelisted.
Anybody out there who's
interested in getting started
and just playing around with the
API, you can do it using
this API Explorer.
So that's kind of cool.
Even if you've been patiently
waiting for the full public
release, you don't have
to wait to use this.
JEREMY WALKER: When do you think
that will be lifted,
that whitelist?
JEFFREY POSNICK: I think we had
an answer from Vladimir,
who joined us in one of these
sessions probably a month or
so ago, who made a promise that
was big but was along the
lines of soonish.
Soonish, still a
kind of a buzz.
No specific dates to
announce right now.
We are making exciting
announcements all the time.
And I think we'll talk a little
bit more at the very
end of the show about another
exciting announcement related
to a launch that we just made.
JEREMY WALKER: So soonish.
Follow our Google+ account,
and you'll know as soon as
that whitelist has
been lifted.
JEFFREY POSNICK: So just to give
an example of how the API
Explorer works.
This is for the
youtube.search.list method.
I'm going to search for YouTube
API as my query string.
I could put in some other
parameters over here.
This is actually really nice.
I didn't even realize
it did this.
When you click on one of the
fields, it gives you the
possible values which is cool.
So I can sort by--
ANDY DIAMONDSTEIN: It might
not be needed after all.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Not at all.
So some cool things over here.
But then if I just click
Execute, I get back the JSON.
So the default response
form [INAUDIBLE]
all the new APIs is JSON.
There's 82,000 videos that match
YouTube API, and you get
back the information about
the first five--
get back the video
IDs over here.
So play around using
the API Explorer.
I think it's a great way to get
started or satisfy your
hunger to use the Version
3 of the API before
it's publicly released.
JEREMY WALKER: Also, V3--
one of the other cool things is
you can reduce the amount
of information you get back
just to get what you need.
So if you just need a couple
of those fields, you can
actually, in the API Explorer
specify, I just
need this and this.
You can see it come back.
So you can see it pared down
exactly to just what you need.
Obviously, that will be less
traffic coming back and forth
so your app will be faster.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Totally.
JEREMY WALKER: Cool.
I know you talked a little bit
about the documentation being
dynamic from the code base.
Could you tell us a little more
information about the
actual code samples
being dynamic?
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah.
Andy and I are still working
out the whole--
ANDY DIAMONDSTEIN: We're working
out the details, but
Jeff really produced--
has tested a bunch of different
functions and been
the first person to do so.
He's produced a lot of--
JEFFREY POSNICK: Jeremy
has, too.
[INAUDIBLE]
full credit [INAUDIBLE]
the rest of the team
[INAUDIBLE].
ANDY DIAMONDSTEIN: I try to suck
up to the people who I'm
going to spend the most
time with in the
next couple of days.
JEREMY WALKER: I'd say Jeff
has done the biggest--
the most languages by far.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Well, OK.
ANDY DIAMONDSTEIN:
So we all agree.
OK.
Whoever has been working on
the API has been producing
some great code samples.
So we want to make those code
samples available to
developers just as, give me the
Python code for uploading
a video, or the Ruby
code, or whatever.
But also we want to have that
same code available in the
documentation.
And one of the challenges with
that type of approach is if
the code sample changes, how
do you make sure that the
documentation changes
to reflect the
change in the code sample?
So we're working out a system
where basically, the code
sample will be updated in one
place, and it'll be integrated
directly into the
documentation.
So when the code sample changes,
the documentation
changes, but also that the file
that's made available to
developers is changing at
the same time, and it's
all the same file.
So that'll be, I think, really
helpful and a key component of
this documentation strategy of
showing you how to do things
and making the code available
in different places.
One of the things that I've
learned-- and I'm a relatively
bad programmer who knows enough
about programming to do
a lot of things, but the wrong
way in many cases.
So it's always helpful to
me to see examples of
how people do things.
And I know that one of the
things that I'd like to do is
make the APIs accessible to
as many people as we can.
So when I look at the Player
demo, I think that's something
that makes the Player API
accessible to someone who
really doesn't know very much
about programming at all.
I think that the people who
are watching this video
probably have a very different
range of programming skills
and probably approach their
development in different ways.
Some people will go and read the
documentation and try to
figure out how something
works.
Some people will start with a
code sample and then they'll
say, OK, well I have this code
example, but how do I do this
one thing that's missing
in the code sample?
For documentation to be helpful
to all those people,
it has to really support all
these different approaches to
development.
So no matter which of those
approaches you take, if you're
the person who wants to just
start with the code samples,
you should be able to just go
and get the code samples.
If you're the person who wants
to read about how something
works first, you should
be able do that.
If you're someone who just wants
to toy around and play
with how the functionality
works, you should
be able to do that.
The integrated code samples
are all part of that.
I'm excited about it.
I think it's going to be cool.
JEFFREY POSNICK: So they're
live in documentation yet.
They will be [INAUDIBLE]
hopefully soonish.
Also soonish.
JEREMY WALKER: Also soonish.
[INAUDIBLE].
JEFFREY POSNICK: [INAUDIBLE]
slightly before the
public launch.
We're not exactly sure.
JEREMY WALKER: That's
great to hear.
I know there's something else
coming with it, something
called Google Developer
Academy.
I'm guessing, Jeff, you're
going to cover this.
But tell us a little bit what
it is for people that don't
know and what we can expect
that's coming soon.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Sure.
Google Developer Academy is an
initiative across a bunch of
teams in developer relations.
It's not something specific
to the YouTube API.
And the idea is to provide
more structured
educational-type resources,
things structured around the
concept of a course that you
might take that's divided into
different lessons.
And each lesson teaches you
one specific skill.
I think the overall idea is you
might pick up individual
skills in the lesson, but you
also really need the framework
of a larger course to show how
everything fits together.
It's fine if you know how to do
YouTube embed, but if you
don't know what the significance
of doing a
YouTube embed is, when it comes
to then using a YouTube
Player API to make changes to
that embed or control the
embed, it's only so valuable.
So we wanted to give an
end-to-end example for folks
to work through on their own
pace and end up with some
working pretty cool
code, hopefully.
So we've done that already for
one specific course, and
that's been a course around
the YouTube Player APIs.
I put that out a
few months ago.
And you can get to it from
developers.google.com/academy, I believe.
That's the landing page that you
can go to and see all the
courses that are available for
a bunch of different APIs
including YouTube APIs.
So that existing course walks
you through doing an embed,
using the iFrame Player API to
actually jump to specific
portions of the video, and at
the same time, have some HTML
on the page that will give you
the ability to define chapters
within a video.
This might be an
example video.
If you wanted to embed what
you're watching right now on a
page, there's different
sections of our talk.
And you might say, OK, at the 15
minute mark, that's when we
did the demo of the
API Explorer.
So you want to make it easy
for folks to jump to that
specific portion of the video.
So if you go through the whole
course that we have available,
you'll know how to build an
embedded Player that lets you
do that sort of thing.
That's what's out
there right now.
I'm also working on
a new course.
And I believe it's going to be
focused on the Analytics API.
It's going to walk
folks through a
more hands-on example.
This is a little bit above and
beyond the code samples that
we were talking about earlier
when Andy was saying how he
wanted to include code samples
in line with the docs.
Those will be stand-alone
programs.
They're mainly stand-alone
programs that illustrate how
to do one specific thing
with the API.
This new Analytics API course
will show you how to do a full
integration using both
the Data API and
the Analytics API.
The idea is to show you how you
could take Analytics data
and store it in a
local database.
That's on top.
Hopefully, we'll get that
done pretty soon.
Lot of other stuff
going on, too.
But check out that in
the near future.
JEREMY WALKER: Cool.
The new Analytics API is pretty
neat, especially for
anybody that's used the
old inside one.
Before, you'd get a zip file
with a bunch of CSV files, and
you'd have to go through
those and handle those.
But now, you can get directly a
JSON or a CSV response back
which makes your life
a lot easier.
I think we've talked about when
all these changes are
coming out.
There seems to be a buzzword,
I've been hearing.
Did you guys want
to cover that?
Is it still soonish?
JEFFREY POSNICK: I didn't want
to give any specifics on this.
JEREMY WALKER: OK.
So we're still at soonish.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Soonish.
JEREMY WALKER: Actually, there's
one more thing I'd
like to cover with the
documentation.
You showed the API Explorer
which is really cool and helps
you get a great start
with the Data API.
But of course, we have another
API that's used for consuming
video, which is the
Player API.
If any of you have used the
iFrame embed, it's a pretty
neat little API that switches
between flash and HTML.
So you can support a lot
of environments.
But you may want to customize
it a little bit.
So can you guys tell us what
resources we give for that?
JEFFREY POSNICK: Sure.
I'll let Andy drive this one
since this is very much a
child of his creation.
That's a fair description.
ANDY DIAMONDSTEIN: This is
the YouTube Player demo.
I looked at this, again,
as someone who's not an
expert-level programmer.
When I was asked to document the
Player APIs or to update
the documentation for
the Player APIs, I
always found myself--
I would create a page, and it
would have a player in it, and
then I would go in and have to
keep editing the code to see
how the Player looked.
It would just take a really long
time to see what worked
and see how it looked.
There's just a lot of opening
a file and updating it.
JEFFREY POSNICK: It was
something like 20 different
player parameters.
ANDY DIAMONDSTEIN: And they're
supported on different--
we have an AS2 Player,
an AS3 Player.
The AS2 Player is deprecated.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ANDY DIAMONDSTEIN: We
had an AS2 Player.
There's the AS3 Player and now
there's the iFrame Player.
Different Players support
different parameters.
It was just really time
consuming to test anything.
I figured if it's time consuming
for me and it's hard
for me to figure out what's
a good way to do it, well,
people who don't spend their
entire work days at YouTube
probably can't just walk over
and ask people on the Player
team what to do.
It's probably even
harder for them.
Can I expand this?
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah.
ANDY DIAMONDSTEIN: This is
a way, basically, to--
there's also two different
components of the Player APIs.
There's a content component,
so you're controlling what
content shows up and how
it plays back or
pauses or when it starts.
And then you can also control
the display of the player.
There's different parameters
to do that.
What this demo lets you do is
basically customize a player
and see how it looks.
You can see the API calls
that it's making.
You can also see the embed
code that if you want to
display that same player on your
own page, that you can
just copy the embed code and
stick it right on your page.
If I can do a quick example,
when you get to--
I probably moved our computer,
which I wasn't supposed to do.
If you get to the URL,
it's developers.googl
e.com/youtube/yo
utube_player_demo.
It just comes with a
video preloaded.
But let's say I want to
instead load a list of
uploaded videos for the Google
Developers user.
I can do that.
I can click Update Player.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDY DIAMONDSTEIN: You're
seeing that the Google
Developers user's videos
are coming up.
As you scroll down on the page,
you'll see that it's
loaded a playlist of
that user's videos.
Here's all the videos
in the playlist.
If you scroll further down,
you can see all the events
that were triggered and the
function calls that the API
was doing to load that
information.
If you scroll down even
further, you can
see the embed code.
And you can just copy this
directly into your page if you
want to show an iFrame Player
that shows a list of the
Google Developers user's
uploaded videos.
If you want the AS3 Player,
you can use the
Object Embed code.
Again, for me, the goal was
both self-interested--
I want to make this easier
for myself to test--
but also I want our things to
be accessible to people who
aren't really experienced
programmers.
I think that hopefully, this is
the type of tool that will
be really helpful to those
people, and then also really
helpful to people who are
experienced programmers, but
maybe in a different way--
and just helping those people
be more efficient.
The other thing that this demo
does, if I go ahead and--
you'll see that on the right
here, there's a list of player
parameters.
These are things that you
would use to control the
display of the player.
So you could say, when my player
loads, what I really
want it to do is start playing
the video immediately, and
instead of using the dark
theme, I want to
use the light theme.
So you'll see that the
dark bar is here.
When we update it to the
light theme, you should
see a light bar there.
So we've done that.
This is the second video
in that playlist.
You can see that it's light and
the video starts playing
automatically.
If you go down here, you'll see
that the embed code has
updated to include those
parameters, so that when you
put this player on your page,
it's going to function with
that functionality.
The goal was to make it easy
to just test things out and
see how they work.
So you might say, OK, well,
let me play this.
And you'll see that there's
a red bar here.
You might say, I don't
like that red bar.
I want to go with the
white instead.
JEREMY WALKER: I can see
how that would save
you a lot of time.
ANDY DIAMONDSTEIN: And
then you'll see
that it's white there.
Just a way to test things
out really quickly.
And so now that we have that
for the Player, I'd like to
hopefully have that same type
of functionality for the new
data API as well.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
I can see how that would
reduce your time a lot.
I know I've had to do that on
not just video players, but on
pages when you're trying
to get the look
and feel just right--
refreshing and changing,
editing, refreshing,
refreshing.
So that's great.
That should help reduce your
time skinning the player.
We covered a lot of changes
which is great.
And these are all coming soon.
Is there anything else we
should be looking for?
I feel like there's so much
great stuff coming.
I couldn't imagine there
being anything more.
But is there anything
we missed?
JEFFREY POSNICK: [INAUDIBLE].
Do you have anything secret?
ANDY DIAMONDSTEIN: Yeah.
I probably shouldn't
talk about it.
JEREMY WALKER: So you got
the API Explorer.
You've got the Player,
basically,
explorer to edit those.
And then we have dynamic code
that will show up as well as
dynamic documentation.
So definitely start checking
that out now and start playing
with it again.
Check out the API Explorer.
It's really awesome.
And if you're using the Player
API, check out the Player API
demo that he just did.
It'll help you save
a lot of time.
So actually, I was going to talk
a little bit about the
Silicon Valley code camp.
I just did that last week.
I did a presentation
for beginners.
What I basically covered was how
you want to use the Data
API and the Player API--
a lot of what you
guys covered--
the API Explorer and then a
little bit just about the
player in general.
We're going to be
coming around.
A lot of the material that I
covered, it was [INAUDIBLE].
A lot of the material I covered
is actually in a lot
of these Google Developer
Live meetings we have.
So if this is your first time,
definitely go back through to
some of the videos and
check them out.
You'll get a lot of that
information if you weren't
able to show up to
one of these--
whether it was last weekend's
event or any future events.
This is just a quick way that
we wanted to be able to give
you the same information
without you
having to go to an event.
So definitely check old
videos as well.
Let's see.
Any questions?
Let's check out the questions
while I'm here.
Actually, Analytics
API, whitelisted.
When will that be
lifted, Jeff?
JEFFREY POSNICK: So we did have
a question about that.
I don't know if it was from
someone anonymous or what.
It was somebody who wanted to
know on the Google Moderator
when the YouTube Analytics API
would be publicly available.
Again, this is not Version 3.
The data API that we're talking
about now, this is a
separate YouTube
Analytics API.
And for folks who follow us
on Google+ or are on our
announcement mail group, you
probably got a message earlier
today from me saying that we are
publicly available at this
point, the Analytics API.
So if you had previously tried
to sign up and you've been
waiting on the wait list,
that wait list is gone.
Everybody can go and
turn on the API
now in the API console.
We have a great set of docs
by Andy [INAUDIBLE]
for getting started with
the Analytics API.
I think we have one somewhat
complete code sample in the
docs that you can work
through now.
We have that course for Google
Developers Academy that I'm
working on.
We'll have a little bit more
sample code in different
languages coming soon.
It's kind of important to note
that we are launching this API
right now in experimental
mode.
So it's flagged as an
experimental API.
It has some legal meanings
according to our Terms of
Service which I won't try to
fully interpret in a live
talk, lest I say something
inaccurate.
But we are in experimental
mode.
One of the main things that will
probably be changing with
the API over the next
couple of months--
this hopefully should not be a
breaking change, but what will
be happening is that we're
going to be rolling out
additional metrics.
So for folks who are looking
through the docs right now,
you'll see a somewhat limited
set of metrics that you can
use in your reports in
comparison to what you can do
via the website right now.
When you run the YouTube
Analytics report through the
website, there are certain
things that are available that
you can't do in the API.
That's one of the criteria
for moving out of
experimental mode.
Once we do add in those
additional metrics and we have
more parity, I think you'll
see the experimental label
drop and it'll be a fully
launched, supported API.
But I don't want to scare
people away with the
experimental label.
Definitely get out there and
start trying things out.
Let us know what your
feedback is.
We're still early enough with
the life of the API that your
feedback really matters and can
affect design decisions
and things like that.
So let us know probably via
the Issue Tracker with any
future requests or
bug reports.
If you have any general
questions about using the API,
programming-type questions,
you should use Stack
Overflow for that.
Don't use that for feature
requests or for
bug reports, though.
It's more like, how
do I do this?
And you give me a sample code,
and I'll say hey, you need to
change X-Y-Z.
JEREMY WALKER: That's
good to hear.
I'm excited for that.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah, me too.
JEREMY WALKER: All right.
The last question is
Google Developers--
are we hiring?
The question is yes.
If you're interested in being a
developer advocate or being
in a developer relations
role, just check out
developer.google.com/jobs.
There's a lot of positions open
including, I believe, a
YouTube one.
So definitely if you're
interested, check that out.
ANDY DIAMONDSTEIN: We are also
looking for tech writers.
JEREMY WALKER: Oh.
Great.
That doesn't mean Andy's
leaving, though.
ANDY DIAMONDSTEIN: No.
JEFFREY POSNICK: This is all
part of a very elaborate prank
which we make Andy
[INAUDIBLE].
ANDY DIAMONDSTEIN: This
is hilarious, guys.
JEREMY WALKER: All
right, Andy.
Thanks a lot for taking
the time to join us.
We really appreciate giving us
a preview of all the exciting
things that are coming.
I really look forward to the
next quarter and seeing a lot
of things roll out.
So thanks, everyone,
for joining us.
Thanks, Jeff, too, for all the
great information and we will
see you here next week.
Bye.